[Music]
[Applause]
this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
okay
I know incredible so far so far hundreds
and hundreds of challengers not one
winner hmm no one's found us making a
mistake because we don't make them well
tonight two fans named Jimmy Pena and
Chris Hall say they think they caught a
mistake they say it happened during a
recent comedy bit this has been all over
the Internet this picture of a Sochi
bathroom stall with two toilets has been
making the rounds and then someone
tweeted this picture of a toilet facing
three chair we are here today outside
ready care in hazlet Michigan
it looks like Sochi it's pretty cold out
but it is not so cheap it is indeed
Michigan many of you may have seen this
picture training the Internet in reality
this picture was not taken in Sochi
Russia it was taken right here in hazlet
Michigan how's that ready
here we go it's so cheap right here I
like this better thanks pretty wrong you
have weird hair
[Music]
like spear maybe strong a a couple of
things this is not weird right and you
know not weird at all Conan second you
guys are calling me weird when you like
to sit on a toilet and high-five your
pal what's that all about with your
pants on with your pants on that is not
how you use a toilet we should know yeah
well sorry Jimmy and Chris if that's
even your real names but you're dead
wrong that bathroom is located in Sochi
Russia and not Michigan we were able to
obtain the rest of your fan correction
video the part you apparently didn't
want us to see America take a look
[Music]
khloe's his dealing coming up a little
later
[Music]
that dancing guy at the end proves
that's Russia and it only happens there
only happens there you can't get those
guys oh no so the challenge still stands
if you think you've sported an arrow on
our show reported team koco.com / how hi
find an error we will sort it out right
here on the air let's see if you've got
what it takes to make chunk meat out of
the maestro